hi it's michelle from laplace and beauty
science chemistry phd skin care known
and sunscreen connoisseur
today we're talking about my favorite
sunscreens i made a video about my
favorites at the end of 2019 but then a
whole bunch of them were discontinued in
the 2020 sunscreen crisis
so here's an updated version i'm sure
some of these are going to test at a
lower spf at some point
so obviously this list is limited by
what i've tried and my personal
preferences
i try a lot of sunscreens but i never
quite get through as many as i'd like
because i've only got one face
everyone looks for different things in
sunscreen so don't just assume that what
works for me will work automatically for
you
i have oily skin and it's also prone to
acne dehydration and hyperpigmentation
if you want to work out what your skin
type and concerns are
and how to choose and use different
products for your skin then check out my
ebook the lab muffin guide to basic
skincare i'm also going to put some
honorable mentions at the end which
didn't quite make it onto my
i could happily wear this for the rest
of my life list but they're still great
and they might actually become your
favorite i personally like high uva
protection because uva causes
hyperpigmentation you can check out my
video on uva for more about that
so i try to find a high uv apf or broad
spectrum rating if it's australian i
also really like the newer uva filters
they tend to be more photo stable and
they give really high protection if a
sunscreen doesn't have these then i'm
sorry they can't join my favorites list
that's just the rules
if you want sunscreens that are
available in the us check out my
honorable mentions list
the most popular newer uva filters are
here along with their common brand names
there are a lot of different brand names
for them now so for example
diethyl amino hydroxybenzoyl
hexobenzoate i'm not saying that again
isn't just umanol a plus it's also all
of these now so i'm just going to be
using dhhb
so these are the abbreviations i'm going
to be using i also hate white cast
my skin isn't actually that dark it's
sort of in that light medium nc20 range
but still
sometimes some sunscreens make me look
like a mime i also wear makeup so
sunscreens need to not peel up on my
skin when i'm applying foundation on top
this is when your skin starts looking
like
it's peeling off peeling depends on skin
type some sunscreens that peel up on me
don't peel up on drier skin
so here is my updated 2021 list i'm
going to start with some products that i
haven't really talked about much before
first it's the la roche posay and helios
chakra fluid this is the version you get
in europe and australia the us
version is completely different it's the
reformulator version of the old and
helios ultra light fluid i really wanted
to light the old formula because the
filters were fantastic and la roche
posay have a reputation for making
really high protection sunscreens
but i have oily skin and a lot of really
liquidy sunscreens
tend to not dry down on my skin and
shift around like an oil puddle all day
this happened with the old fluid crave
beauty ultraviolet
queens green vanessa mile milk these
formulas tend to do well if your skin is
dry but i
hate them they make my foundation bunch
up and go patchy and it comes off on my
fingers all day
so i was pretty skeptical about this new
version because when it comes out of the
bottle it looks a lot like the old
version but it actually works completely
differently on my skin it's lightweight
it dries down nicely it's a little bit
dewy but not too greasy or sticky it has
no white cast and it's fragrance free it
also doesn't sting my eyes now with
icing i think this varies a lot with
different people
i've heard some people blame octokrylene
and avobenzone but for my eyes i don't
think it's actually down to the filters
i've tried analyzing the sunscreens i've
had icing and no ice sting with
and there just doesn't really seem to be
any sort of pattern there it might be to
do with the concentrations of the
filters or the overall formula and how
that travels with my face oil and sweat
mecca recentlyish reformulated their old
to say face super screen
this was really popular in australia and
it was one of my honorable mentions last
time
whenever a favorite gets reformulated i
think we all get really nervous but it
turns out this new one's great
it feels and smells and applies pretty
much like the original
it's lightweight it sinks in easily it's
moisturizing it has a moderate floral
scent
unfortunately i left my tube at my
parents place and so this is the old
formula the inactive ingredients look
the same
it's just the filters that have changed
and it's been an upgrade the new version
sells itself on being oxybenzone free
now i don't really mind oxybenzone but
if i had to avoid a sunscreen filter it
would probably be oxybenzone
and so many sunscreens in australia have
already formulated it out so i get the
decision but the thing that really
excited me was that they added bemt to
it this is a newer uva filter it's
really nice and photo stable and that's
why
it's been bumped up onto my holy grail
list biore uv aqua reach watery essence
is the next one on my list this is the
2019 formula i started using it when i
was trying out a whole bunch of cult
favorite asian products which i reviewed
in a recent video this is really nice
and light it claims to be 80 minutes
water resistant from what i can tell
water resistance claims aren't
officially regulated in japan and there
are a whole bunch of different standards
around the world so it's hard to tell
exactly how water resistant this is so
for example in australia and the us
water-resistant sunscreens have to
re-meet the labeled spf claim after
dunking in water but in europe they just
have to get back to half the spf
so a water resistant sunscreen that's
labeled spf 50 in europe might get
downgraded to spf 25
in australia and the us but this is one
of the nicest water resistant sunscreens
i've ever tried in terms of texture
it only peels up a little bit when i put
foundation on top there is a generous
sploosh of alcohol in this but it
doesn't dry out my skin
and it doesn't sting my eyes the biggest
downside to japanese sunscreens is that
they tend to reformulate after a year or
two
which is great from a technology point
of view but sometimes it can be hard to
work out which one you're buying and
which one people are talking about and
based on their history they are due to
reformulate this year so hopefully not
before this video comes out anessa
perfect uv sunscreen skincare milk is
another sunscreen i talked about in that
cult asian products video
it took me so long to try this because
it's a bit difficult to get
and it's expensive compared to other
asian sunscreens but i've had friends
raving to me about this since like 2012.
yeah i am a next level procrastinator
but i finally tried it and it lives up
to the hype
again it's 80 minutes water resistant
but i'm not sure to which standard
it's also rubbed sweat and heat
resistant it feels a little bit heavier
than the byrays sunscreen but the lack
of peeling really makes up for it for me
and it looks really nice under makeup
here are my favorites from last year
which i still love and haven't been
discontinued yet check out that video
for the full reviews
first we have the ultraceuticals ultra
uv protective daily moisturizer spf30
mattifying this is still my ultimate
go-to sunscreen i just have zero
problems with this this is actually the
sunscreen that got me into wearing
sunscreen every day
the only issue i guess is that it's only
spf 30 so it's slightly lower protection
than a lot of the other sunscreens i'm
talking about but for everyday wear i'm
fine with spf 30
higher sps tend to feel heavier and
break me out so this is a compromise i'm
willing to make
because i can apply the proper amount
without feeling bad
ultraviolet supreme screen is a really
lovely lightweight sunscreen that works
really well under makeup as a primer
it's hydrating without being shiny or
sticky like a lot of other hydrating
sunscreens
i love that ultraviolet sunscreens were
developed by women who have a lot of
experience developing products for women
some brands seem to ignore that women
tend to wear makeup over their sunscreen
these have been tested with tons of
foundations and they don't tend to ball
up
ever it's also been recently released as
a larger 75 mil version for only two
extra dollars which is awesome asly
action day moisturizer is what i
recommend to people in real life in
australia who want to start wearing
sunscreen every day
a lot of the time they're pretty
hesitant because they've had bad
experiences with sunscreens that are
really greasy
heavy white smelly and this just sort of
blows their minds
i think it's really good to know of a
gateway sunscreen like this
it's cheap it's light it doesn't have a
white cast it doesn't have much of a
scent
and it's easily available in canvas
warehouse which is everywhere in sydney
so they don't have to wait for it to
arrive and they're not tempted to start
using the chemical exfoliant that i just
gave them without also wearing sunscreen
it's a bit tacky on my skin but that
doesn't seem to be a problem for most
people
it is spf 30 but again these are people
who were not even wearing spf 15 to
begin with so
this is a win unfortunately from digging
around on the tga registry it looks like
a reformulator version was approved like
last week apparently this is just the
sort of thing that happens to
any sunscreen i recommend the new
version doesn't have octanoxate i'm
guessing
it's to do with the whole reef save
thing i'm hoping it lives up to how
great this one was but i don't know the
formula looks very different and it also
includes mbbt which tends to be
a little bit white on my skin so i guess
we'll see chemic has been reformulated
apparently the new version has worse
white cast
this is obviously my curse claire's on
purity sunscreens have been discontinued
because they tested at lower spf i have
a video about that
and some of the reasons why sunscreens
tend to test at lower than expected sps
in post market testing i also recommend
watching a deals video which talks about
a loophole that it looks like some of
the contract manufacturers exploited now
onto my honorable mentions these are the
sunscreens that didn't quite make it
onto my personal favorites list they
didn't tick off some of my criteria but
they're still really great and i think
they could turn out to be favorites for
a lot of people
some people have actually told me they
are their favorites my top honorable
mention is probably cancer council's
face day wear moisturizer matte
texture-wise this is very similar to the
ultraviolet and the mecca sunscreens but
it's a lot cheaper and it doesn't have
the newer uva filters
the biggest issue is that it makes my
eyes water but
again i sting is pretty personal it
might be fine for you this seems to be a
similar formula to the natio daily
defense and the ombro daily defense
they all have the same filters at the
same percentages and the nation and
cancer council sunscreen seem to have
the same ingredients list the ombre
sunscreen isn't listed on the tga
register anymore so i can't check the
ingredients
it seems like audi aren't planning on
bringing this back anytime soon and even
when it was available it was available
for like two weeks every year this is a
bit naughty of me but i wanted to shout
out the cancer council bb cream as well
i love it but it is not technically a
sunscreen this is regulated as a
cosmetic in australia which isn't as
strict as other australian sunscreens
which are usually regulated as drugs but
sunscreens in a lot of other countries
are regulated as cosmetics as well
so this seems to be a very similar
formula to the matte moisturizer which
is a sunscreen but it's tinted more
but the tint is light enough that you
can apply it in the same amount as you
would with the sunscreen and when i
apply that much it actually makes my
skin look really
nice and like a better version of itself
it looks super super natural
but it stings my eyes and i was in such
denial about this that i tried it for a
full week after my eyes started stinging
and so i just went around crying
everywhere but having really nice
looking skin
so for products like this it might be
worth wearing a different sunscreen
around your eyes
my favorite for this is the neutrogena
shear zinc mineral sunscreen stick
this uses zinc oxide and most people
find that this doesn't sting i generally
don't like sunscreen sticks for the rest
of my face
because they tend to feel heavy and clog
my pores it's also difficult to work out
how much you're actually applying
so i mostly use this around my eyes it's
water resistant
and in general sticks are a lot more
waxy and so they tend not to move around
on your face with oil and sweat as much
as a regular sunscreen lotion i actually
rubbed this into my eye right before
filming for science
and it's fine so yay science this also
applies smoothly without chunks breaking
off and it works well for me under eye
shadow now the biggest question i always
get is what about us sunscreens
well you don't have the newer filters so
none of them can make my favorites list
but here are some sunscreens that are
available in the us which i really like
these two sunscreens from bondi sands
and everyday humans are australian but
unlike a lot of other australian
sunscreens that you can find in the us
they are actually approved and available
in australia the biggest difference
between australian and us sunscreens
that really matters
apart from the newer filters is the
broad spectrum label
this tells you about uva protection
which i go through in my uva video but
very briefly
in the us this means it passes one
criteria called the critical wavelength
so at least 10 of the area under the uv
absorption curve has to be at 370
nanometers or higher
that means there's going to be a bit
more uva protection but in australia
it's stricter
so on top of this there's also the
requirement that uva protection has to
be at least one-third of the labelled
spf
a lot of sunscreens that are considered
broad spectrum in the us aren't actually
broad spectrum in australia europe is
the same as australia for this
instead of broad spectrum they use the
uva circle logo everyone is obsessed
with the bondi sand sunscreen at the
moment
it has no white cast it's a little bit
sticky on my skin but it's fine once i
powder over it
but it is a lot lighter than a lot of us
sunscreens i've tried it's also four
hours water resistant which is a big
bonus
there's a face on a body version and
from the ingredients they look like
they're the same formula but i haven't
actually tried a tube that's labeled
face yet to confirm
bonded sands are also releasing a whole
bunch of new sunscreens which i'm
excited to try everyday humans is a new
brand for me this is resting beach face
it's spf 30 which is great for everyday
use is really nice and light
i should also point out that there are a
lot of international brands that are
approved in australia so they also pass
australian standards
i think we sometimes forget about this
so this includes sunscreens from like
neutrogena la roche posay
so you might already be overlooking some
higher quality sunscreens that meet
australian standards
now for some zinc sunscreens i don't
hate i don't think this is a surprise to
anyone but zinc oxide and i do not get
along i can always feel them on my skin
they tend to be thick and clog up my
pores and mess up my fringe
sometimes they dehydrate my skin and
make it go flaky while also feeling
greasy which is like top 10 skincare
betrayals there's usually white cast
they just don't spark joy but i found a
few that i actually quite like and this
is a new and exciting experience for me
it's ultraviolet lean screen
paula's choice super light daily wrinkle
defense and naked sunday's
collagen glow mineral sunscreen i think
a lot of brands have caught on to the
fact that if you put a bit of tint into
a zinc oxide sunscreen
then it reduces white cast even if that
tint doesn't necessarily match
people's skin tone all three of these
are pretty much invisible on my skin
even though they all look like different
colors coming out of the tube but i've
still seen people with darker skin
complain about white cast from the
ultraviolet and the puller's choice i
expect it'll be the same for the naked
sundays since it's even lighter in tint
than the other two paula's choice isn't
actually approved in australia as a
proper sunscreen
but it is really nice and light in
texture which is amazing for a zinc
oxide sunscreen the other two are spf 50
plus which means they have more than
double the protection yeah spf 50 plus
means
spf 60 or higher in australia things
work differently here there was like a
whole emu war
anyway these two are a fair bit thicker
in texture they're a little bit like
paste
i have to powder quite thickly on top to
make sure my fringe doesn't stick down
on them but
if i had to wear a really high
protection zinc oxide sunscreen it would
be one of these two
this is the face version of every
sunscreen evie are a swedish brand and
they use the special technology that
gets the sunscreen into the top layers
of skin so it doesn't rub off easily
it's very cool i've talked about the
data that backs up their claims before
but this felt a little bit sticky and
uncomfortable on my face apparently with
swedish customers
this is considered really light and
comfortable it might be because i've
been sport with these light
asian and australian sunscreens or it
might be because it's so humid in sydney
i still use evie a lot on my body though
so that is it those are my favorites let
me know if you've tried any of these
and what you thought or if you have
sunscreens that you recommend that i
haven't mentioned before like subscribe
and follow let me know what other
categories of products you want me to go
through my favorites of next time there
is probably a 50 50 chance i'll be
talking about sunscreen again
you